thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what's going on guys
I see some of you already pulling in
through
as you can see we got like
four minutes and something
I'm trying to determine the best way of
doing the sound
because I need to have the sound
to record
or you guys get what I'm saying I don't
know yet I don't know yet any of you
guys got an opinion on the matter
see if I use this
what's going up happening
as you guys can't hear the audio
unless they have found a way to fix it
which I guess I can try it just to see
if they gave you like another option
where you can have an output at the same
time
every time I stream on the PlayStation
it's always issues because they don't
have as many options that you have on
Xbox
here's the piece for it
I have like a little container down here
excuse the piece to the
there we go
see if this works
oh
I only got like three minutes to figure
something out
is it on
um
nope it's not on
oh my God
I found an option
bam found this
this is like an old old headset I have I
can hook it up to the monitor
so I can actually communicate with you
guys
now look
I don't know how long I'm gonna play
this game I'm gonna be real with you
guys
I will be communicating in the chat to a
degree
but don't expect me to like hardcore
communicate in the chat
some gameplay I'll probably do but I
don't know like how long I'm going to be
like steadily in the chat
what's wrong
okay
I'll have to do it in the morning
see the difference is
you guys are paying the internet I'm
paying the internet
can't really unplug my internet to make
me do something
can you bring me a couple Waters please
this game's about to start
and why why can't I hear oh yeah I gotta
change
the audio
there we go
ah here we go guys
wait a minute
a minute
till greatness
a lot of people have been coming at me
over
God of War
thinking I care I don't care
I always said God of War was going to be
a good game
just because I have some opinions on God
of War in general doesn't mean I think
it's going to be a bad game
some of you
need to realize that
just because it's my opinion don't mean
you need to feel offended
and I'm not necessarily talking about
anyone in the chat
uh you know some of you follow me on
Twitter
but you guys get what I'm saying
it's up to the 16 people here man four
three two one ready to play
God of War Ragnarok
oh this is gonna be interesting
let's just do this
come on like like two and can you give
me the little
thing over there
my little pillow
ah so I could be comfortable
thank you
yeah that's fine
uh
I hope I'm gonna enjoy it man
I got to get my little Volari pillow
make sure that I'm comfortable playing
this
HDR I don't think I have HDR in this
be real with you guys
I favor performance
television 3D
we'll go balance we don't need anything
extra
see I got my wireless
okay gotta stay hydrated got my Waters
we about to we about to really go on
this
oh
let's do the God of War recap what do
you guys think we'll do the God of War
recap let me turn on this overhead real
quick
oh you can hear Kratos grunting
I can hear cradles grunting
ugh
God of War recap
the boy's mother is dead
I speak in all around
the gods of these Realms don't do it
kindly to Outsiders trust me
our God
leader of the banner once yes but no
longer
there's only one person alive who can
get you and you need to go
first you need to cut off my head cut
off my head
cut off my head
oh my God
I'm getting hyped
to live but the truth is I was born all
right we done we we know the story of
God of War
foreign
so what do you guys think I should do
man
I know there's not a lot of people in
the chat right now so I'm gonna give you
guys like
30 seconds
I'm not doing God of War
I'm gonna point that out right now I'm
not doing God of War
balance
I feel like I could do no mercy
I feel like I could do no mercy if I if
I truly wanted to
I do feel like I can do it
we got a No Mercy okay hold up
engage oh they have like a um
a q a thing here now
no mercy
all right we'll do no mercy
I wonder if I can record this the same
time that I'm streaming
foreign
[Music]
no it's not
it should it looks like it's working
tell me if the stream downgrades a
little bit guys
DLC of War nah man we gonna be a little
respectful I want to bet because of this
guy we I have King's knees because of
this guy
just making an arrow of some sort
just love the
the audio in this game the audio is very
fluid
you know they they match tones very well
ah
hungry
yes he was making arrows
what can he not make his own arrows
Kramer's got to make his own his arrows
I won't talk as much during the uh the
cutscenes because some of you might want
to actually enjoy the story
but gameplay it's on it's on in the
gameplay
[Music]
oh oh my God man the
I've been waiting for this game for a
while Chuck
I've been waiting for this game for a
while
foreign
pass out
we got like a moose of some sort
see God of word does a very good job at
building the tone
what is that
ready
you know there's not a lot of games that
did what God of War did
[Music]
got that seamless go from gameplay to uh
cinematic cut scenes looks identical
so this part's a little bit on Rails you
don't look like you have to move a whole
lot but you got some sleep
quite sick dress I know oh he was a
little better yesterday
he's eating I'm not giving up
thinner is the uh that wolf that's in
or whatever it is the wolf that's in the
cutscene
[Music]
oh God the beginning the beginning we
getting straight into this
not again
[Music]
if she ain't feeling whatever man
I like that that's a really good way
now we're gonna have like a running
moment where we have to get around from
that easy
she never does stay alert
get this chick off of me
do something Petraeus just got you
gotta get away from her I'm trying
yo see immersion immersion
you have to fight her dad
get that beater up get her off you man
there you go
hold tight protection Stave is near
what is the protection state
is it like a certain part of the area
that she can't go on
well oh
certainly
oh
please don't make me do this
is he stopping it
[Music]
what's going on
through the state
we made it
let us go home
it's Becky fauna up
what's going on
I'm sorry I couldn't take the shot I did
not wish you two
keep hoping she'll let it go
there is no letting back go
yeah
I guess killing balder really did bring
on fimble winter
stop snowing after that day
I think it's ever going to get better
someday
but there was still ahead of us Caesar
is a good way we must be strong
narrating
without like being too
too much if you guys get what I'm saying
like you're getting a little bit of
backstory while still telling the story
I got it
yeah
yeah well he is a God so it would make
sense that it does that and that staff I
mean
he's been stabbed through the whole
abdomen when he had the uh I think it
was the sword of Aeons I know
I don't know I remember what that sword
was called the sort of alons is in Fable
the sword of the Gods but we'll get the
deal
are they eating a deer come on girls
what I'm talking about at the end black
truth when
after the end of three he stabbed
himself and then it just disappeared we
still they still ain't explain how that
happened yet
and I think that's what we're going to
see
us fenrir
you okay boy
oh this is where the stranger was wasn't
it
he ain't doing that well
still hungry
come on boy
you need to eat
why
too big
oh there you go
oh boy he's gonna throw it up
the dress the time draws near uh it must
prepare yourself
for what
he's still eating he wants to live
it's dying
what happened to him
did they explain it
is there something in the lore of why
this is going down the way it is
a brave boy
fast and strong
but you can rest now
okay
I'll be okay
you can let go now
you have to let go
man that's uh they already hitting you
in the fields game ain't even really
done anything yet
so if not
what's up uh simpat you know I can't
pronounce to save my life man
hmm
it's on
so
why is his eyes turning white
well he is a God
what happened
do you do that on purpose
or is he just finding out what
we Trading
what
no
we gotta bury him
night does not stop our enemies
Kratos know something's about to go down
what for
drinking is all we ever do ever
it's not enough
we can't hide forever
we don't prepare for a fight for which
we are not ready
we'll go
time is running out
the prophecy say femble winter leads to
Ragnarok
war is coming
whatever Loki's supposed to be doing
he's supposed to be doing it now I
thought he was lucky my story doesn't
end hiding in these Woods oh okay I
should be out there finding out who I am
who Loki is I will not allow you to pick
a fight with gods
I don't want to fight anyone I just want
answers
what mother one
looks like we never will
we need some keys from King I already
got I already got uh King's knees man
they they and they box back there
they're right there on top of the Shelf
[Music]
it looks good man so far so good I
really like the opening immersion they
did
oh there's that head
well
I recognize that don't expression
anywhere
to tell me what went wrong
I hear you man
you can experience the story with me
how's the line taking it
he goes to bury him oh
damn it
all right brother
good night there
I will say that
God of War 2018 looked amazing but I'm
not seeing like a huge jump in you know
the Fidelity and that doesn't
necessarily mean a bad thing you know I
feel like God of War 2018 to this day
stands the test of times I don't think
that you could say that 2018 doesn't
look good even with today's standards
Saint Monica did some Miracles with that
I haven't seen a whole lot about the
game either
but I I don't think
what is what's going on
Kratos
what's going on guys are you joining me
all right
okay it's definitely a little bit of a
an increase I can say that now seeing a
little bit more of some lighting and
stuff
yeah
very
I will follow so is that the boy's
mother
yeah that's what I'm saying
fresh kill
at least it didn't suffer
am I to decipher your grunting
tell me your thoughts we
gotta do a wolf yes but it does kill
it is the natural order of things your
words are misguided
don't tell me let's get him I'm a God
we want to help
a little wolf ain't gonna do nothing to
me let me add him no don't
I didn't move
it wouldn't let me think we found beyond
our Steve
he found his way inside what's up Chris
Jones appreciate it man I said he would
we should have acted it was not our
concern
what is
problem doesn't have to reach our
doorstep for it to be our responsibility
I like her
if we have the power to limit the harm
it could cause
we should act I do feel like if this is
a flashback we should see a little bit
more of the angry Kratos and you see her
taming him throughout the game
all right so I don't go that way
what's up post up
get this content post up man we got to
give other people what they want
could she pick it up
not Kratos
equal rights equals equal rights is
equal fights
make her pick that up
man Kratos totally simple right now he's
totally simple right now I'm just I'm
just being real with you guys
very
that's a wolf
great
it's gonna be a big predator
what is she doing
Radha
oh he's having like flashbacks or
something
that ain't good
so Chad you think they're gonna kill him
at the end of this game
because I I've been trying
he never came back from Buddy and the
Wolf
I've been trying to stay away from
spoilers
this is where we fought Bolter it's kind
of cool he fixed the uh the [ __ ]
too unstable brother the lad wouldn't
try it
The Lads a little bit this has not been
opened no pants this way either
oh here we go
tracks heading down to the Frozen River
that's most likely where he did the
burying
fires dwindling now
where else could he have gone from here
he's worth too much to Sony
locked I could feel you on that
this is where he buried the wolf looks
like he lit a fire by the kennel
commiserating with the other pups I
suspect
where'd he go
he was snatched
he said that was already locked
there was no other place to go
do I pet the other one
he crawled through here
you seem troubled in your sleep even for
you
this is what those people were talking
about on Twitter like going through the
caves and stuff
a bad old days in Greece oh
looks like failures
tell me something you don't mean to say
you're talking to ghosts again brother
no
but it is something more than memory
what's going on use your words not that
the truck stop here
and you are not alone
all right here we go guys
doing get out of here
yeah
what you doing what you thinking you
doing
how do you dodge
is it the eye is it the snow that's
stopping like a full full judge
I don't know
I hear you
oh [ __ ]
got the Invincible Shield
they're just disappearing it's kind of
weird
how do I get my there we go
don't make me come at you don't make me
sin for you
yeah get out of here
[Music]
appreciate the super Chef oh I I can't
read it yet
unless you guys are trying to low-key
get me killed by reading stuff in the
middle of going protection Steve there's
a tree up ahead yeah
baby time to go home and not fall asleep
what's up Forte what you not home for
okay so I'm saying open this late
be careful man don't fall asleep driving
explains our trespassers what happened
here
yeah it does I it's like I said it's not
like a huge a dead animal a struggle we
must find atreus I between the Savage
beasts and marauding Raiders he may have
sought shelter follow the trail we'll
find him
midnight release
how many people Reserve this game Forte
I'm curious on that how many people
Reserve this game
I will never get sick of that
hold up
just the sound man you can never get
tired of that
can I hit these
but wait recall that any idea what could
have made the line wander off we argued
he accuses me of
hiding from Odin Heidi from only
sensible to keep a little profile I
don't like how I reckon they woke up
like we're not seeing too much
interactions Odin for on his own for
those accusations to be used
Giants had you dead on some wall full of
well
good
so I don't like how do you believe in
I'm skeptical by Nature I don't like how
they're talking about Odin and we
haven't really seen Odin in any way
shape or form yet it's not alive
bloody idea
my story at 12 years came oh that's
what's up I'm glad it's selling man
hold up to frost stuff that there we go
what's up man
yeah get dealt with
let's go
uh the the winter update I I was trying
not Forge a little bit guys
um
I ca I can also say
I gotta sit down and really
figure out forage ow
L
all right someone behind me
I like how they have color coordination
makes it a little bit easier to
determine who's uh who's a boss who's
not ow
there we go
I need some help though there's that
trail gone
persona 5.
yeah I need to uh jump back on that
grind I played Persona so much I think
that that's present preventing me from
really putting a lot of time and Persona
on Xbox
I haven't even finished the first palace
yet I'll get to it I'm gonna review this
game and I really want to try um
ogre
oh God there's someone behind me
jump Rock
the biggest question I'm gonna have on
this game
they must have a camp nearby I know what
you're thinking brother but atreus can
handle himself
taught him well so he keeps telling me
uh Jason that's up in the air so far I
gotta play a few hours before I can give
a clarification what I think is gonna
happen
uh James so far it's doing well
you know I'm trying not to talk too much
on the cutscenes because uh I know some
of you've never seen the cut scenes
including myself in the trailer so I
want to make sure that we all enjoy what
we're seeing pretty thoroughly sure we
can find it quietly
boy you can do that
I'm not really worried I'm worried about
the health a little bit no
no so the wars we have came from Raiders
I need some health
I'm not in there
death from above
allege once in the air purse R1 unleash
Death from Above attack
okay I
like how he tells you like where people
are
I see you
all right what is this
describe this
I need some health
hold that
I like the freezing mechanics
I need some help goes through here
bet you
because people did kind of like spoil
that Thor's in the beginning of the game
uh so I'm kind of curious what's gonna
happen there
oh oh this
okay
that one's got a sling look out brother
we're gonna get them back here a little
bit
on your left
no no
I need to get the pairing better
oh
fire from above
hold this
hold this
get a little bit of Health looks like
there's a chest down here
hmm
some money I wonder what you could spend
money on in this game
on the left
I should have did that lost all that
health
I guess
where is that fire coming from
yeah you're dead
oh
hold this
here you go
hold this
don't think I don't see you
okay
foreign
there we go
Petraeus are you here
that wasn't too complicated you're
seeking shelter kept moving when he saw
the Raiders and the bear came battling
after
Rampage I'll give it that you think the
bear was chasing atreus well just as
likely the bear was hopped in a Chase
was chasing him to help you just asked
where are you oh there's a bear
that's like that bear from uh elderly
you guys know the bear I'm talking about
oh oh God okay
all right so the yellow one
is bad okay
let me grab that
all right
yeah yeah yeah
I can't Dodge the yellow one
okay I don't like Circle being the the
dog but
oh
God look at this
oh what you doing
look here it comes
oh you know what
we're gonna make this thing Frozen
stopped again
oh oh come get it
come get it
hold this
oh
get him off of you
foreign
let's go
foreign
oh gotcha
[Music]
no no no no absolutely not
I needed that
dog's doing a little bear doing a little
bit of damage to me guys
come on
I think that might be dead
uh
they got my guy yeah I was fighting the
bear man get a little too uh comfortable
a little too confident
he's got like a little stagger system
there at the bottom
man how many times you gonna do that
but y'all make him mad
he does a lot of damage with that
come on
see it's so inconsistent with whether or
not you actually hit him or not
say I don't like how it's Circle either
[Music]
get him get him
it is kind of weird that a God's taking
this much time finding a bear I will get
that
what are these bears in North mythology
being under attack on our God and and
Greek mythology
foreign
look he's got a gauntlet of some sort
too
yes which way is
what's going on with uh is the stream
messing up guys
foreign
messing up guys tell me if the stream's
messing up
apparently Trace is turning into wolves
now
all right fenrir
and then um
I'm not sure
I was so sad
and then I was angry
what's going on I don't understand why
sometimes my stream
just works sometimes it doesn't I hate
running the internet I have
there was a bear
charging and
I charge back
that had to be a dream
no emotions
let me transformed you see
ah
it makes it look I didn't know I could
do that
it makes a little bit more sense why
there was fighting and it took Kratos so
long to defeat that bear knowing now
that it that it was a trade because now
that wasn't just a regular bear fighting
Kratos it was like a Godlike form of a
bear
more than that I need answers answers
you don't have answers only your mother
had
that's how she withheld
what if there was someone who could help
us
someone that could give us answers about
the Giants and who Loki's supposed to be
wouldn't that help to understand where
I'm becoming latreyas
listen to me
he's got a lot of scars on him I'd have
killed you
earn control we will take more
unnecessary risks
inaction is also a risk
you taught me that
stop thinking like a father for a moment
and start thinking like a general no
no
like yourself
foreign
Kratos is critically injured
the bear was was pretty killer I ain't
gonna lie
see that's what I'm saying Aaron I don't
mind stuff when they explain stuff in
the lore of why stuff happens sure
are we going to discuss the boy becoming
a bear yeah are we not now
we need to repair the protection Stave
and get home what happened to the
protection Steve you did so you're
blaming me I am not blaming you Latrice
well tell your voice that
you kind of did blame him you said you
did
who is this
companion arrows yeah go ahead admit him
come on
what's going on over here shoot her
get her get him
there we go
it's a lot besides your gift of language
and hearing teachers thoughts are there
any other new magical abilities to
report not really what a thin rare what
about him when he died cast a spell no I
didn't but I saw light I don't know what
you're talking about hmm
check your thimble winter perhaps
IA
that's probably how thinner gets so big
what's with all what yours Victorious
seriously that or any prey you might
have been dragging I suppose not sure
that makes me feel any better
oh I can't wait to fight like Thor this
one
oh so he's the one casting the the
Spells
foreign
it's interesting
[Music]
I didn't mean to
intent does not matter
the consequences
oh
what
what can we do you killed their mom
ain't much you can do
nature will take its course
[Applause]
[Music]
protecting a little one
foreign
I kind of feel bad
storms are coming isn't it cold enough
we are almost home
I wonder if we're gonna how quick we're
gonna fight Thor
where's the sound uh these things
oh bam
good show they they have increased the
gore a little bit but it still needs to
be more
radar
I hear you
oh God
watch the fire
wow
a lot of those guys
it's been like this all night he must
have been inside The Stave when I fixed
it
I'm curious
what atreus is actually capable of
what are we still doing out here brother
hey spawner you're not scared you're a
brave girl
good Brave girl
that's right address I'm just checking
too bad
yes sir
evening's goal that was entirely too
eventful
well I'd met it was a bit like all times
there a moment
three of us navigating some hitherto and
happened upon Patcher forest in a while
since you've joined us if that's what
you mean ah well just tired I suppose
you've seen one deer hunt you've seen
them all how can you feel tired when you
never sleep there are other kinds of
tired laughs you'll see when you're all
done now I have a proper rest my
brothers
probably where that cutscene is going to
happen where our Thor shows up at the
front door just remember mines but I
still have the first one to beat you
ain't beat the first God of War post up
are you serious
what was that the ball
oh he's like they found us
oh we know who that is
[Music]
can I come in
I have me
you will not find me good company when
it's gone
I'm sure we'll find lots to talk about
look at they act like they're going that
they were gonna fight at that moment in
the uh Trail as Sony know what they do
look how much bigger he is than Kratos
yeah post it you should feel ashamed of
yourself on that one man
this place
he is gigantic
foreign
saying it's overrated
there's a lot of aspects of
is that his ax I've always wondered
this is weird
you could have told me before I poured
why are you here
just
being polite
8.58 is a fair score
um reasonable person
are you
a calm and reasonable person
if the moment calls for a calm
I'd say the moment cost for calm
what's going on
no God
is it Odin
it's Odin
you know who I am
back before winter set in
there were some misunderstandings
the credible one
but I think we all have a better idea of
who we're dealing with
now what you did to his boys
self-defense
dying is what we ACL live for
and let's be honest they were kind of
useless
[Laughter]
but vulgar
he had value
he was my best tracker my closer
yeah his mind was gone sure
but he had his uses and now he's gone
because of you
you follow me
oh
you have a debt
you're no fun anymore
what do you want
Odin could sound a little bit more
dominant I'll give you that
how about peace
how does peace strike the esteemed
retired God of War how about we just
don't kill each other
how about you stay home kick up your
feet seek no quarrel with me and I'll
have none with you
of course it means that that one
that one has to stop his search for tear
yeah
we know what you've been up to stop it
tears always are dead he is dead
and then that's it there was Square
[ __ ] I'll even sweeten the deal
I'll let you keep the prisoner
that I know you stole
that's right I know you're in here
somewhere you silver tongue little [ __ ]
why should we believe or without you
one of your promises ever been what
there he is my all partner in crime he's
lost weight oh my God your snow is white
he's lying what kind of wisdom is that
can't the smartest head alive see past
himself
see that we all want the same thing all
right
here's a deal I know you can trust
I'll settle your debt
with my ex
keep
prayer off your back
keep
your boy
safe
it's really all you want isn't it
so what do you say
hello
no
don't take all day
all right
about time
I've been waiting for this you're not
from here we got a tradition called
blood pains it means I get a piece of
you for what you told from my family
you'll pick it up
wow
that was for Boulder now show me this
God killer I've heard so much about
oh God I did not seek that fight with
your brother I don't care
you can't fight without your ass coward
how were you ever a God of War
I have no problem fighting Thor
but you need to stop pick me up like a
ragdoll
your memories I can't believe they lost
to you oh
you are finally showing me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
just holding back
okay okay he he played me he played me
he played me off
let me see the monsters
oh he got me
he got me guys he got me
good night good night man
let's go
oh let's go Thorpe
we're gonna freeze this up man he gets
you every time I go for that
[Music]
I need to just hide behind my shield
right there
oh I bet you the yellow thing goes up
right you should be better than this
man that move just does a lot of damage
get off
wow man he he he really putting it on he
putting it on me
all right all right let's do this let's
do this guys
come on
all right so
wait
oh hey
let me see the monster inside come on
come on
come on
man
oh
my God
I'm just better at dodging like I'm not
I'm not a a shield person I'm just not
I just feel so like exposed when I use
that Shield like that
man that movie is ridiculous
oh I really love that health
I'm going for that help guys we're going
for that Health chat
Boom come get it Thor you fat
I don't like how that's so close
yep there he goes
[Music]
they're not sorry about your statute
hit him with a big ass post if you're
not fighting dirty you're not fighting
right
you just gonna keep throwing those over
and over again
I love how this dude is talking
you know he ain't interested enough of
course Kratos is saying
I'm gonna freeze this
oh
good
oh God maybe I should have dodged that
yeah they both did
to be fair you ain't really doing much
either Thor
oh I like the soundtrack though
is that all you got it's not a pretty
weak move if I say so myself getting
pretty predictable there Thor
oh
I like the hammer though
you think you can come here become a
daddy get a clean slate that ain't how
it works you're a destroyer like me
where is the axis
oh no
I say when we're done
I'm not leaving till I see the real you
get up
the author just low-key killed us and
said we're not done
oh that's cool
oh now he's using abilities from the
last time so it's not too much you know
we just gotta Dodge that red move
he's gonna do the other one
[Music]
actually I I didn't do that I'm gonna be
real with you you're giving me credit
for something I didn't do and I'm dead
he'd give me credit for a little bit of
stuff I didn't do I didn't kill the
valkyrie Queen we'll be real with you
guys
I love how they're giving me credit
though
I want you to get a little bit closer
come over here
come over here come on
yeah it is
here hold this
there you go
you do it twice right
come on man
this is the foreign oh
you don't seem like you enjoying
yourself too much
dog
again
here
what's up Thor oh
you know what Thor here hold this
oh
you hit me there man that hurt oh nope
I'm gonna hold that
I ain't ready Thor no getting too
predictable there Thor
okay okay mate maybe maybe that was a
little bit
oh what's this
I ain't playing what you doing
yeah
this feels like God of water like the
the original ones
true
you put him last even in death the [ __ ]
you saying Oh Lordy shot Us in fear of
you he died of the woods you gave him oh
we got a model father
this feels familiar but don't matter
huh
I wanna see the God of War
that movie's really simple there Thor
you better stop doing that moves
there's like a little AOE around them I
should learn how to dodge that better
what you doing what you doing
being too predictable Thor
oh oh oh oh
clever
clever won't keep me
there's some health over here
the same moves ain't gonna beat me Thor
it's just not happening
oh oh
how'd that work out for you Thor
out freaking Thor
come on do something different Thor
something different
oh okay you did something different okay
I'll give you that oh you did something
different again I give you that oh you
do something different again okay he he
kind of
he kind of like locked me there for a
second
you know
I gotta start from the start
ow
what's up Thorp here you go
come on man let's do this again come on
come close to me
yeah let's go Thor oh come on Thorp
oh
okay you can't Dodge that so that's on
me
come on Thor come on Thor
oh
I should probably use that Shield more
to be honest with you
oh I want that
and I want that hit
I need to learn Dodge that second one
oh
I need to learn how to dodge that better
nope
no
totally can use this hold up let me get
that health
[Music]
I see why my sons spelled to you
lesser version of you but I am not my
sons
and your boy our father has plans for
him
there he is
[Music]
there's the God of War
consider your blood debt pain
oh we don't even kill him
I don't like that
I wanted that hammer
I'm not feeling that
now Odin is with the trash Oh no
I'll go get a Gateway ready come on then
ain't a long walk
foreign
well good to see you making new friends
yeah yeah yeah you know we made
that wasn't ever sure you were listening
at least it was good to see the ax hold
their own
kind of the point after all
is there any more dialogue I don't want
to open it too
oh just got them locked down tired or
ain't you noticed
one and done look at the name one and
done
once you chase Odin off you got another
place to lay your head tonight and I
don't mean that talking though
found in my hole oh yeah and wants to
stop the all [ __ ] from spying on you
or Raven picking your house this
planners while you're asleep in nothing
that's what not go get your boy and
putting you up to his place
oh can I see where he knocked you
through the roof
yeah right there
he went that way
really man I feel you
not nothing wrong with a little joke
I was about to look for you
are you
what does he want
pay for the roof
and
he invited me to Asgard
Daddy
I couldn't hear once he went outside
I told him no
obviously
I don't know I don't trust him I don't
trust it contrace I feel like he he
would go just to try to get info on what
his mom didn't say
for me
I wanted to tell you
I really did but
now that you know there's something you
should see no
trust me you'll want to
broken
then let me regain it
let me show you what I found
besides we haven't seen the last of Odin
or Thor
and clearly they can just walk in and
blast holes in our home whenever they
want
there's only one way to get them off our
backs
we gotta kill them and I think I know
how
sir
where is the blades
where is the damn blades man the ax is
cool
but I should have been able to fight
Thor within blades
there's those plates
so we
gather your things
what is that
oh my God
all right Gear Up
all right so we got the chest armor
make make Kratos look a little a little
beastly
armor built from the husk of some of the
dirtiest creatures in all of non-realms
it provides the where maximum coverage
increasing their defense
all right
um
can I go back no it's going to make me
fortify one of these
I guess we'll just do that one
skills
Leviathan
so it looks like you can do certain
things
all right let's look
view attachments
the fears around equipment's collect
abilities
status helps
okay
the blades of uh chaos then you got the
shield people really
don't have nothing for the blank chaos
yeah I like the ax though I do like the
ax but are you ready those blades man
we can't forget the blades
he took the coin
he's like he he put a hole in my in my
roof I'm gonna use that point
if I change your bastard oh no he threw
it that's a little too much we didn't
need to do all that
where are we going the old temple in the
wildlife why it'll be easier to explain
once we're there
oh see anything else while you went
outside yeah he said he doesn't care
about yodenheim anymore that the Giants
can keep their secrets he's averted
Ragnarok his own way
you think he knows all the Giants are
dead I'm more concerned that I no longer
matters to what's he up to
what happened here
so close to home and read us warning
with one another now those are not their
arrows something else is out here
what if we're gonna end up teaming up
with Freya
I don't know Odin
Odom seemed very adamant on not having
war and fresh I feel like there's a
reason for that while the state was down
that or or didn't cocked up the
protection spell altogether
what do you see
just animal tracks
almost to the bridge oh
the bridge gave out gonna need another
path to the temple why would you come
out this way alone
calling me here
whoa that one's still alive
I don't care
we're not supposed to stay there no
we're we're moving on hold
what was that something strong and
dangerous
oh yeah being all the way on guard
there's the temple now we just need to
find a way around
this way
got some coins
oh god it feels nice
what is this
yeah get dealt with I think I'm gonna
sit here and fight you
make me laugh
you said there was someone who might
help us get answers about the Giants and
Loki you ain't here
the old God of War in these lands lands
who is dead well for a dead man who
didn't seem pretty keen on seeing he
wasn't found right he knows tyr could
unite the Realms against him
plus here was the Giant's greatest Ally
so enough
friends
it feels so nice having those blades
guys
you can never not have a God of War
without those blades
okay came just naturally down there like
nothing happened
I hope no one else drops
telling us to draw
can't we die now can we
I need these
skill tree available
all right so we got skill trees
uh we're gonna leave those alone for
right now
I would love to have gotten the health
can I get the health please
we might need that house
there we go
get full health
all right
there we go
moving on up
I think I think I backtracked a little
bit hold up
there we go
yeah we've definitely backtracked
uh that pillar wasn't in the way last
time I came
it's not in the way anymore
I don't know why you would want to have
it come on I was saying
here was an Allied vagina though he'd be
on our side if we find him
and if anyone might know who I'm
supposed to be
if he's out there
gotta find him
how can we not those are many ifs
address
no you'll see soon
recall that ax
there we go
little man
I think the little man could play God of
War God Wars on the PS4 guys
what do you think I can't imagine what
the last time but he says he has
evidence to come this far let's see it
many dead here we should keep moving
playing with too late
I got you
there we go
I like I like that
ow
another Raider to the left
oh I got hits from the back it's just an
empty game of course it's pretty
um
I do think that there's a high chance
that this would run just fine on the
series I said it would look just fine
many dead here clearly probably it'd
look a little bit different than
than what you're looking at now because
this is on the PlayStation 5 but I don't
think it would look bad by any means
yeah we're gonna kill this too fast
there we go
we need this fire
yeah I see you guys
we're gonna get this fire all going
come on come on come on
come on come on
let's go
how are they back
oh I need these health
man the fire is a little ridiculous
this is the last
oh
can you get her over here
I hear you
I like the interaction with like trees
and stuff I feel like that's a pretty
good
pretty good to have
looking around
do I go back up
my only fear
is that we're going to come to a
situation we was in the first one where
you come into that like amazing dwarf uh
you know boat or fight or whatever that
dude's name is and then like you get a
lot of like troll stuff
um hopefully they don't do that because
I do feel like they understand that that
was a huge issue with the first one
so we'll see
how criminal winter wore down all the
helpful magic we acquired it's somehow
new Terrors only flourish as if On Cue
I like to stop using that one move
because I feel like it's getting me
killed
cool
[Music]
there we go
what's this kill
winter man yep you got it I wonder who
they mean
I'm assuming they mean this purple
barred person
oh God
I see some chats just give me a second
I hope you're enjoying Ragnarok I've
just finished rescuing I think I'm on
that part right now
um apparently that's the God of War
uh no I've so far I'm enjoying it I
can't say I'm not
ah he has gotten rather good at that
remember when you used to get on you
when you climbed up
yet another grizzly scene
okay
shoot him
[Music]
you know they got they gotta make stuff
a little bit easier for people man
there's a lot of Health in this game
never really having issues with health
what's this way
uh nothing
he's gonna say climb shed but this is an
awful lot for one month
oh
who is that oh God
the huntress
what is this
it's horns are glowing might be a weak
point
oh
please
let's go
where'd she keep getting this fire from
[Music]
I need to go in
oh
bam
the hunters like there's not a lot of
like lore behind why you like like
everyone should be scared of the Hunter
thank you
[Music]
probably gonna die
it's not even hard to dodge is that you
can't really do much until you have
those little glow things yeah right
there
I might be able to pull it off I don't
know
gotta go in with that nope barely man
10 out of 10.
I wonder if they have anything replacing
the Valkyries
you know I'm using the the blades I feel
like I I'm able to do more with the
blades and be quicker with them too
because you got to keep in mind it takes
a couple seconds to actually like bring
that
bring the uh the Leviathan back to you
let's go keep right Bumper in her man
so what you doing what you doing
you gonna shoot I'm gonna just go close
yeah see it's just a lot easier when I
don't have to
because this move's not that hard to
dodge like the only move that is
difficult is that one
she ain't really that hard
we wrote you
oh that moved it a little bit
someone gave this skate I don't agree
with the 10 out of 10s I feel like
there's so much you can find wrong with
games that it's just like to me it would
be really hard to get at a 10 out of 10
games
that's just me
you know you know the review is just the
subjective opinion regardless but I can
understand why people would like the
review system to be a little bit
differently
no
come on man
you guys can do it
oh
you can do it
see the the arrows explode but they're
not too hard at the Dodge after a little
bit
you just gotta learn the way that
they're going
foreign
I can almost
I can almost put money on that
simple winter freyr the radar Store
Newton barging in and her stalkers
playing in our Woods
even anymore
a light Rune attack former Mastermind
okay
Aruna gas
I remember those
okay
yeah
[Music]
father
this is definitely the sense of quotas
from Sun to get into the Sony game uh
Sony games and Sony Gamers this game
looks like an 8 out of 10 which is a
great score but to them it's not enough
um
it's like I said reviews are subjective
uh so far it's a pretty solid game
pretty good pace
um I got I gotta play a little bit more
I found telling the stories of giants
Giants the panel on the right would be
their fate yes
yes we found many I have seen them well
there's more to them than we realized
well the collapsed pillar is new but the
shrine is just on the other side
okay
you think
there we go
oh yeah it's one of those things where
you open it
what is this
you watching
I mean you ain't wrong it is a little
bit more the same but that's not
necessarily a bad thing you know if you
find you a
a formula that works good you know it it
definitely could work out for them again
come on
address wait yeah I don't think he's
waiting
foreign
s Were Meant to see
these shrines tell their stories to the
world
but it turns out the real stories
the secret stories
those they kept here
inside
you remember the story of skolnati the
wolf Giants
Odin captured them because he thinks
it'll help him control when Ragnarok
starts I remember but that's not the
whole story
see this shows the giant setting skull
and hobby free they are free
is this the past or the future
depends when you're looking at it spoken
like a giant see the wolves are safe
somewhere in Vanna hunt it's not the
first place Odin would look I suppose
there they are chasing the sun and moon
old habits until look the moon gets
stolen
somehow atreus
see hottie's got nothing to Chase and
they say Celestial theft is a victimless
crime
what's going on not totally sure who
this is
but someone comes along and rescues the
moon and then the moon blocks out the
Sun a total eclipse I haven't seen one
of those in a hundred Winters
but then they chase an arrow and things
go back to normal
what does any of this have to do we're
coming today
here's Ragnarok do you see who's leading
the armies against Odin that's tear if
he's gonna be around at Ragnarok that
means he's got to be alive
right we're here
can this be Odin told me he killed Tia
and he trusted me at the time or so I
thought what if he didn't kill him what
if he's just had him locked up some more
all this time we are back to IFS
wait we are going home wait I have one
more thing to show you
it's just out here
what is this
everything I found
well almost everything
that's giant craftsmanship
you've been to your home again
no I found it in one of the other
shrines oh that's right
you visited
I well all of them
all the ones I could still get to in
midgard anyway
I don't know what it is
but it's important
just like all this
when I was inside one of the shrines
I saw an image of tear imprisoned
but I couldn't tell where
there are hints inside the other shrines
you mentioned
black smoke and the bleeding Earth
but we can never figure out exactly we
yeah centuries been helping me Cindy use
that look I talked him into it it wasn't
his idea
I just needed someone to watch my back
black smoke
eating Earth
could the prison be a Muslim unlikely
Odin's got no presence to speak of in
the primordial realms with the bleeding
out sounds like a mine eye
the realm of the dwarves perhaps Sparkle
Fame that's a good bet
their minds did Bell's black smoke and
Odin's had his thumb on the dwarves for
a very long time
that's it then tearsen's photo finds
somewhere imprisoned in a mine
so
what now
oh
okay
this way glad even if we can set our
looking for Tia how do you have us
getting just battle fight you know
audience had all traveled between Realms
locked up tight Sentry said he had an
idea or two about that sinjury is full
of ideas
that looks kind of cracked there
huh
all right how do I get down here
2018 was mildly mid couldn't believe it
won more game of the year then look I'm
not a big fan of Red Dead Redemption so
that's not the perfect person to ask
about that I personally do feel like God
of War is a better game but
I'm no fool I do understand that
Red Dead is a high quality game and if
you like that game I definitely
understand
how do I get down here
can I stalk
maybe there's something that I have to
like throw on it or something I don't
know
we're gonna go look
oh we gotta jump on it though
yes I love Elgin
outer ring is a very
high quality game it's going to be hard
for
God award to beat that
offer to the Lord not much they stepped
outside
told us about it I wouldn't buddy
not to us
I feel like Odin might be
tricking us into going and looking for
that dude
come on
purpose remember when we fought our
first troll out this way I remember you
lost control
let's not talk about trolls
there was something down here fighting
without a shield it is not my first time
I already know how to use that move
nasty hey you're all right brother
true now
yeah
yeah oh
yeah
aggressive I feel like it could be a
little bit more gory
just a little bit and I'm not gonna say
it's like horrible or anything like that
but I do think it could be a little bit
more gory
come on
of course
you keep missing me Fam
INE
he has power holding back the gore
um nah I think Sony's holding back the
gore I don't think they want
any of their games to like
be that excessive anymore I don't know
that's just my opinion
I heard it was the series you guys are
ridiculous
curiosity against him
goes with being young in my youth we
lend obedience and is that what you wish
for him
but rather he's going to walk his own
path
if you don't want him walking away from
you and smarten up and walk with him a
while
if we could find a way to open run
travel to Spotify that there'd be all
sorts of useful equipment for us enough
you will go really but if we do not find
here you will abandon your search for
good all right
you won't be sorry
I do think God of War 3
is the best God of War I've played so
far now I haven't beat this game
but I do think it is the better God of
War
how do I get up there
sometimes I don't be liking these games
it's like Corridor space like this
because you have to go around especially
it doesn't have a map so you have to go
around looking
for
the way you're supposed to go I don't
like that I think it's I think it's wet
what's going on over here
foreign
well if you'll follow me Brock mentioned
he needed somewhere safe to spend the
night and I believe your favorite
dwarves can help you out with that
we're still your favorite dwarves right
yeah I'll take it
after you my friend where is this going
and I'd prefer it to stay that way not
looking at anyone in particular
s after that Thor incident we thought we
should make up some rooms until you can
figure out your next moves
nearly there
they still kind of took that exact we've
settled here in the realm between Realms
it's nothing much but it's safe from
fimbal Winter safe from Odin's eyes and
you really can't beat the view if you're
into shimmering grave voids that's
amazing sin
we have a plan to talk to you about
actually game looks pretty nice though
come in come in
now if you would just wipe your feet
very thoroughly I'll wait
you're not gonna wipe your feet are you
okay then your bedrooms are there the
kitchen is just over there anyway
Kratos
snack I do not need a snack what we need
is your help getting to sparto Farms so
we can try and rescue tear to tear alive
I mean that's what it's okay
I told him everything
you waited my son in disobeying me no I
kept an eye on him on your behalf
nothing risky everything very safe
somebody else speaking what's important
right now is that we try and open up
travel between Realms again
you said you know a way yes I do I just
it's just there's
it's just a lot of mud then why haven't
you opened the way already man well to
be frank there was
something we needed your help with
oh
the holder Brothers finally require the
services of the smartest man
Sony games seem to be required to follow
the same formula in a glorified visual
novels I agree with you to some degree
there play I would agree with you
all Yarns need to happen to him
he's too damn tall now he grew
it looks like
that
I Blame You
now come on then let's get him something
that fits at least it's just getting
older you dark flat didn't you ever have
an awkward phase in your youth hey yes
suppose what's done is done
but you'll be putting your foot down
from now on if you know what's good oh
he's trying believe me
all right let's gear you [ __ ] up
before you go off galavant
do you know this
no The Shield busted up good
wouldn't you rather I just whip you up a
new one
it is
important to me
yeah I'll see what I can do
in the meanwhile how about I fix you up
with something to get you by
e
welcome to the hunter Brothers craft and
upgrade armor weapons attachments and
items using collected resources very
different store services using the
bottom Navy bar
pro has enough materials to forge a new
Shield
I only got materials to make one of
these in the here and now you bring me
more resources we'll see what we can do
hmm
this is the one
which is regular shield
that one requires a lot of um
I'm gonna go with this one
game reviews are much easier to impress
the stories than movie critics I think
that's why we have so many hacks like
don't
uh duck been making games and they
clearly want to make film and TV
um I actually think there's a lot of
truth behind that I actually feel like
Kojima should probably stick to making
game
should probably stick to making
taller making movies and stuff
thank you
found some items you left behind tossed
them in the chest what would you do
without I'm gonna go look around check
out my room
tell Cindy when you're ready
this place is great injuries you built
it all yourself you know it
all right let's see here how do we
unlock the Realms we'll just need
something from back at the workshop
follow me and be sure to bring ahead
bring the head
so where exactly is tear being held he's
imprisoned in a mine somewhere that's
all we know so far hmm
the realm is full of Minds you realize
you'll need help narrowing it down oh
you should talk to Durland who's Darlin
he's a cousin of ours sort of works for
the city on safety issues should have
access to all kinds of information on
mines
and I know he's no friend of Odin that's
why your mother sought his help when she
was trying to whip up a rebellion ready
a rebellion did you know about that I
did not a Rebels
sounds like exactly what we need I think
you missed the ta-da
never mind
I'll have this oiled up in no time meet
you at the Gateway outside
Rebel leader darling
if that ain't giving up all right see
you out there century
you hear that
we'll just need to buy Frost in the head
Brock do the touching oh this would be
the part requiring my assistance then
you said it this device here has been
crafted to your measurements um it'll
help you get a better look at the
problem with those bifrost eyes of yours
I want to really learn how to use the
forge mode on Halo infinite so I'll
probably
dip my toes not a little bit shine this
light
[Music]
[Laughter]
open open now
I was really hoping not to use the
eyelid clamps clamps do it
that's it that's it good
now
release
it that's our cue come on hurry I'm
coming I'm coming
restful because Ant-Man what was that
for you'll see soon enough
just there
oh interesting
let's see no permanent damage I'll show
you I'm not the timer Joey [ __ ] yeah
takes a joke
[Laughter]
why could he do that I'm kind of curious
was there a particular reason why he was
able to do that now that we've
reconfigured these gateways to use
idrisil seeds you won't need a travel
table or a bifrost lamp anymore
I also used it for light okay good note
I'll figure something out but first come
on let me show you how it works
okay aim your key at the roon for
spartal fine on the right then
concentrate
to get to any of those Realms you'll
need a seed for them
that's midgard in the middle I know
you're not going back there anytime soon
sure let's go
this should take you to the wetlands
outside need of a Lear City just make
your way to the town square and ask for
Dural in a Tavern you sure they'll know
him at the tavern darling's always been
an in Federate inebriate I suppose he
might have completely changed but in my
experience eh did you want to come with
us oh they do use a lot of
[Music]
we've been here like five times
wait what I said good luck
they do make it a little bit easier
because
there's a lot of Storytelling going on
but they are you it does seem like to me
they're using a lot of everything stuff
too
to tell
oh
a lot of uh stuff that you would
normally see to hide like loading and
stuff I know that Dev like clowned on
people saying that but that's what it
really feels like
we can probably use this boat if I can
just get it free careful what
why are these things so bad
all right
ow
on your left
[ __ ]
come on
I see what already off to a lively stop
betrays
you dropped your guard I got the boat
free though
I still can't believe Mom let a whole
Rebellion here against Odin and never
talked about it the fact that it didn't
go well might have covered that notion
what your mother did before we met her
was her business did you ever ask
Eyes On The Water
they are resources
oh I'd like to have more conversation
if you never ask Mom about what you used
to do what did you talk about when you
met
like did you just say
woman God the house I will go to catch
fish in the river
and then leave for five days no
your mother was far better at fishing
than I
sarcasm great sarcasm
red wheel is blocking the channel
so these are wetlands huh
pretty accurate it is a bog
smell is making my eyes burn you know
what it is a fair bit more important
than when I last visited now that you
mention it
hmm
here was a friend to the Giants
I wonder if he and mom ever met
if he was a part of the Rebellion here
that certainly possible the God of War
often advocated for the Giants although
I don't recall if he ever declared
Allegiance outright
well he was killed for a reason well
rumor to be killed
oh [ __ ]
there we go
[Music]
what's up
father
I knew I was I knew I was messed up
look I can't I can't disagree with you
Beer Barn it does look very similar to
the first one
okay
on your left
how many times that if you hit me
one more
[Music]
what's happening
these little monkeys man
there we go
man I hear you
I prefer this to be honest with you
I like how they go off the map
foreign
yeah I hear you man there's so many of
them
all right I gotta actually like fight
reserved wise I can't just
go in there
thank you
all right so there's one
oh it's not a big deal
I just gotta learn how to fight them
that's all
[Music]
they really coming at me though man
yeah yeah I hear you
foreign
[Music]
no
[Music]
to be honest with you guys
yeah I'm enjoying it there's got to be
some way to turn the wheel up here
why does Kratos need
to climb those anyway you should be able
to jump with him like just when you get
to the bottom it just lets you jump up
to the top I don't like how a God has to
climb a chain to get to the top
with all the mining here the land's
bound to be a wee bit bother
I think you can reach the Wheel from
here
[ __ ]
jump
oh okay
wow good job getting it to lower exactly
where we need it I was thinking because
it's so warm maybe it's not that the
cold hasn't made it here yet but maybe
it's just different in Spotify
winter doesn't strike all Realms quite
the same way
weird that Bumble winter doesn't always
make it
want to and midgard it does but as you
can see the effects here appear far more
gaseous in nature observe the geysers
observed the aforementioned aroma
these effects were present before in
some form but now see all right let me
push start real quick all right so like
as you saw that part right there where
we went under the bridge
it's things like that that make me
question that that was meant for loading
or that was meant for immersion I do
feel like that made it more like
what's what I'm looking for immerse in
the game where you would have to do that
to actually get through that section of
the map
oh these things
oh
I see you buddy
incoming
[Music]
these little things are annoying when
you touch these other things with them
oh there's another one
God
thank you
oh my God stop it
I try to throw the thing down couldn't
throw it down quick enough
oh those things are everywhere
got to be aggressive it looks like
Thor wasn't that hard he just kept
repeating the same attacks over and over
again
but the water doesn't reach
what will oh that well
okay you froze one of those geysers
is there another one somewhere
well how are we supposed to
foreign
didn't really go into much detail when
they do stuff
oh my God
foreign
foreign
perfect
all right got it
uh father up there
of where
I feel like games like breath of the
wild and stuff kind of like ruined that
immersion like this
game looks like massively big but when
you actually come down to it it's not
that big at all it's actually kind of
small
hey did that guys are up there just get
stronger
when you froze the guys the pressure
must have changed for the ones around it
maybe there's a van
we can get a better look
oh
God
I mean I see it getting stronger
how do I get up there though
foreign
um
thanks for uh stopping by man I think I
might be heading to bed here soon too I
don't know why like I'm just tired
I'd like to know what I'm getting stuck
at though
I get a better look I am on the vantage
point
foreign
yeah I feel you man I'm having a hard
time finding what I do here
like you can't go anywhere over here
that just leads back down there
it seems like it wants me to go there
but I'm having a hard time finding that
foreign
where do I go
see this is the point I have with this
game like
they don't really I don't like when you
get stuck on something that's just dumb
like this like they don't really go into
much detail they don't have a map so if
there's a part of the map I I can't see
I'm having a hard time finding it
maybe he wants me to get up so I can
throw it up there
shut up and get a better look
I gotta be able to
yo
all right that was simple
yeah back to the boat
I must hit that thing like three or four
times and it wasn't working
could you imagine them siding with Odin
well all too often people have blinded
to all but that immediate self-interest
loading off of them safety and defying
him can be quite dangerous maybe they
just need a couple of gods to come along
and take the fight to him that is not
why we are here
I was only joking oh he's not a joke
especially when gods are concerned
tend to retire as an ally for War I just
I'm trying to keep our options open
let's just keep moving I'm glad we're
out here exploring a new realm maybe we
could just try to enjoy the warm
looks like we gotta find a way to open
that gate if we want to get to
neitherville oh my God another gate to
open
I get annoyed when they tell me to do
stuff like this
back out of the ground again
too fast then how should we catch it
flank it attack from behind
you did it let's see what it dropped
a bunch of stuff
father up there
foreign
I'm not gonna lie I just don't like the
fact that you have to like do little
stuff like that to to get over here to
to Branch out the exploration
like if you can jump this little thing
here you can jump this pretty easily
then why can't Kratos
jump this
he's supposed to be a God I just I've
never liked how they did that on this
like I don't know you know I get it
lore-wise it makes sense that's why you
want to do it but I still feel like
maybe there's a better way
where is it
Rock behind your brother
foreign
just the Gore man it's not the air
I'm not gonna lie that's a huge thing
when it comes to to God of War is just
the gore and
sometimes I feel like it's just not
there
oh I think I get it if you freeze the
geyser the pressure will turn the wheel
foreign
how do I get up there
you want to bring that down
what about the thing above it
I don't know
okay okay
[Music]
maybe you could try hitting the Rope
holding the block yeah I I get that now
can you see anything from that block
yo
that's one of kavasio's poems very high
bro you should collect any others you
find
forged iron
what if I may
what exactly are you hoping to learn
from Tia well like I said I was hoping
he could tell me something about Loki
I'd also like to hear some of his
stories
traveling to other lands giant stuff and
maybe about what it was like to fight
back in the day
just for the history obviously history
let's hope tears in a talkative mood
after being imprisoned for so long
but all of Odin's captives can be as
charmingly volleyball as myself we have
no proof tears truly here
right
that earthquake earlier
you think there will be another one it's
on light for you but geological
disturbances tend to be unpredictable
the geysers and smell here are worse
because of fumble winter
maybe the earthquakes are look ahead
oh here's the doors now this looks like
a city welcome to neither of your
brothers
hey to work
yeah the pairing is a little off to me
just a little bit I'm not saying it's
like horrible I just don't like it
I'd rather just dodge
it only sound an alarm like that if I
still had my body and was fearing the
notion of being detached from it I know
that for us though they are scared
it was definitely an alarm I'm afraid
why is everybody hiding stay alert
foreign
there'll be no help to be sure best we
find the tavern scenery mentioned on our
own and hopefully let us in
is that a statue of Odin they must
really love him here oh for you
Century hello I'd return your surprise
but I did know you'd be here I've got
something for you
thank you
okay
take your time
what is a dwarf
you know I'm glad I came back here at
least once before Ragnarok
oh if these cobblestones can talk
then they'd have mouths
filthy disgusting mouths
do you mind if I fiddle with your bow
oh you are a long overdue for a
replacement
taking advantage of certain material out
structural sensitivity to Sonic
vibrations has been something I've been
meaning to try for quite some time now
thanks for uh finally trying it
What's it gonna be this time
patience I find it's best to see these
things
in action ah
there
oh take aim at that gate there but
before you lose
say
Alpha
well I certainly didn't expect you to
disturb half the creepy crawlies in need
of a leader how was I supposed to know
they were there
[ __ ] come on thank you
I looked at the chat for one second
even before most well got a warrior
infection
uh the performance mode is running fine
for me
father
all right give him one more
[Music]
Okay so
darling
it's injury any idea where the cabin is
do I look like I've ever been to a
filthy Tavern
this way
best of luck
seems like neitherville is locked down
because of us
Outsiders are not welcome here
I imagine that large statue of Odin has
something to do with it well everyone's
hiding on this side too ordin's
occupation of this realm has its hooks
in deep
but there aren't any guards patrolling
we're clearly not a threat
why hide resist and you made an example
of to keep the rest in line
self-preservation can outweigh bravery
for even the strongest of folk fear
keeps them safe and alive
tavern's got to be around here somewhere
maybe we can try knocking on some doors
for directions
yeah because clearly they're gonna
answer that
um
let's just keep moving
looks to be an artifact from the Dwarven
resistance a fire bomb from the chief
anti-odian propagandist and darling's
Rebellion quite a sharp witch he had
until she come check resistance
laughs
are we going straight into someone's
house is that what's going on here
foreign
is so firm any Outsider is considered a
threat sounds like an organism if I ever
had one
another of courvo's poems
it was a little bit of exploration on
here but I do think it's a lot of fake
exploration
[Music]
are you guys
three hours trained for three hours I
think I'm gonna
get a little bit of sleep
but what we'll do real quick because I
still got about nine minutes is I will
rotate the camera a little bit
and we'll we'll talk we'll talk a little
bit about the uh the game so far
so
First Impressions I would say that's
what this is
it's a
I definitely understand why people clown
on obviously
you know I think there is some truth
where people feel like this is like kind
of like a DLC
but I would it's like I don't think
that's a bad thing I think if you
enjoyed the first one you would I you
would want more of that in the second
one
and I don't think that just people
wanting that's a bad thing but what I
will say
is
the game that I just played
it's fun and I think that's all that
really matters in the end you know you
got the RPG system it's returned they've
uh done a really good job while making
it a little bit different uh so so far
so good now I do think there is some
issues with what I'm been playing like
for instance that last section I didn't
like that last section it's literally
take a boat to a thing throw a nice
thing open the door
rinse and repeat for like for like 30
minutes like gameplay Loops like that's
not fun to me uh but so far so so good I
I think that um
the combat could have improved a little
bit I don't think it's bad or anything
but I do think that you know the combat
could have improved uh this entire time
I do feel like
it does feel a little bit
lacking and maybe outdated to a point
but it's like I said so far so good well
I will I don't know if I'll stream any
more of the game
normally I try to give you guys like my
first impressions of it and then I give
you the review uh I don't know we'll see
we'll see but I appreciate the people
that came through
maybe I'll stream this one more time but
until then attic out I'm probably gonna
eat and go to bed I appreciate everyone
for coming through